now over to nile horn and louis capaldi
who surprised fans in dublin over the
weekend by putting on an impromptu
performance that's right the pair were
out and about on grafton street in the
irish capital when they walked by busker
jasper coupen and couldn't pass up on
the opportunity to join in
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay imagine
busking out in the street and then you
know
that whole crowd shows up
nile and i mean just like that's wild
the one thing i will say is all those
people were there
i hope they dropped jazz for some change
i hope everybody dropped jasper a little
change after that come on guys
let's go that literally brought tears to
my eyes and like chills all over my body
because you know to do a performance
like to sing
on a street for people walking by
sometimes they stop and enjoy it
sometimes they walk by you sometimes
you're annoying to them like it takes a
lot of courage to go and sing on a
public street every day
um so just for him to have that moment
and to feel the crowd and have these two
incredible singers perform with him like
i just uh it just gave me the feel like
i just that's the stuff that i like live
for those moments so that was like
really sweet